black m juste ça en est où le projet de
film parce que je sais que tu es en
train d'écrire une histoire avance bien
après j'aime pas trop en parler parce
qu'il n'est pas il est papa concret
encore octobre à me dire que j'ai non
mais ça arrive ça arrive et tout à ton
honneur
merci yahia maître gims qui a dit que
section d'avec sexion d'assaut pouvait
se reformer ces groupes ouais aussi
ouais on est aussi tu veux pas en parler
si c'est bien sûr sa part ça on peut je
kiffe mais ouais ça va ça va arriver
vient d'arriver c'est sûr non non ça va
c'est beau ça
[Musique]
j'adorais et voilà je suis comme un
trophée viendra ici un plaisir à sa
femme lancer dans la fiction veulent
parfois j'aimerais me lancer dans la
fiction je place toujours en henry un
petit film et tout ça mais j'ai encore
le moi aussi j'étais vous je me lance et
tout beau